Kocher: All right,
Hello everyone.
Welcome to App Engine
Nitty Gritty.
Um, we put up one of those
Google Moderator things.
So if you want to jump
over there
tinyurl.com/
AppEngineNittyGritty
You're welcome
to submit questions
and we'll take them
from the mikes as well.
Um...as people
are trickling in here,
probably people
are grabbing food.
I'm just gonna tell you a bit
about what we're
covering today.
Um, one is that for folks who
went to Brett's session
yesterday afternoon,
he had a session
on scaling Apps on App Engine.
There is gonna be no overlap
at all with that one.
Um, we will be covering,
you know,
also things about scalability,
but none of the same things.
We definitely recommend
his talk to us both if you
didn't catch it.
Um, so we're gonna talk about
things that are unique
about building an App Engine.
How you can--you know,
when you're on a system
where you expect to have
some errors,
how you can build something
that's stable and reliable
on top of that.
Um, knowing that, you know,
some of those parts
can and will at times fail.
We'll also talk about some of
the lessons we learned
and recommendations about how to
make your Apps scale well.
And we'll also talk about
integrating external services.
In our case
that was AmazonEC2.
We'll talk about
why we did that,
why you might want to do that.
It could be
a different service.
Uh, but just looking
at how you might have things
that don't fit
on to App Engine that,
you know, are important
to your App.
We are from FrontSeat.org,
which is a civic software
company up in Seattle.
And we were founded around
the idea that software
is getting cheaper
and cheaper to build.
And because of that, we can
start applying software
to, you know, civic issues.
Things where, in the past
it might have been
prohibitively expensive,
but with the falling costs,
there really are some new
opportunities out there.
Um, I'm Jesse.
This is Dave and Josh.
And I'm the lead developer
at Front Seat.
These guys each run their own
consulting companies
and have been working with us
for a long time.
And they've been very involved
in all of our work
with App Engine.
Uh, I'm going to give you
a couple examples
of the kinds of things
I'm talking about
with Civic Software before
we dive in.
Uh, this is a site we did just
after the election last fall.
Where Obama had said,
"I want to appoint
a Chief Technical Officer
for the country,"
but nobody had defined
what that role was.
And so we put up a site
just really quickly.
It took us about a day
to launch this.
And let people submit,
discuss and vote on ideas
for what that position
should be about.
What the priorities for that
position should be.
So you can see that the top
result here
was about the combination
of net neutrality
and accessibility .
Uh, earlier last summer
we did a site
where students
who went to school in a state
other than their home state
could go and say,
you know,
"I'm from this state.
I'm at school
in this other state."
And the website will tell them
where your presidential vote
will count more.
And then it would help them
register to vote
and get an absentee ballot.
So we have
a whole bunch of projects.
I'm gonna skip over these
other ones.
If you want to know about
the kind of stuff we are doing,
you can check out frontseat.org.
It links to all these things.
Um, everything from
utility bill designs
that promote conservation
to satire about
the payday loan industry.
The project we're gonna
talk about today
is called Walk Score.
And, uh--
before we dive into that,
you know,
the context of all this is
that we're a very small team,
we have a lot of projects,
and we need to minimize
our overhead
and our maintenance.
And that's the context
for our use of App Engine.
So we wanted to bring a civic
software service to scale,
on a budget
with a very small staff.
You know, no sysadmin staff
to sit around
and monitor it all the time.
Um--so on to Walk Score.
Walk Score is a web site
that lets you measure
the walkability
of any neighborhood
in terms
of access to amenities.
So it's, how much can you do
without getting in to a car?
Um, it's--
I'm gonna give you
a demo really quickly
of the original
Walk Score website.
Uh, it started out
with a Google Maps smash up.
So I'm gonna search here.
You can search for any address.
I'm going to search
for the Moscone Center address
so you can see
if our network cooperates.
Um...
My monitor also seems
to be a little bit confused
about what size it is.
So sorry that
it's off-center here.
So as these searches complete,
it pulls up a bunch of amenities
in the neighborhood
and it calculates the score
up here at the top.
From 0 to 100 of how walkable
that neighborhood is.
So there's a ton of stuff
around here.
You can do a lot of things
without getting in a car.
So you get a very high score.
98 out of 100.
And then on the side here
you can see things
like the restaurants,
the coffee shops.
Um, you've got parks
and schools.
All these different amenities.
And, we've got
integration with Yelp.
So, if you look
at the Yorba Buena,
it'll search for reviews.
And it pops up
a little picture there.
You can click through
the reviews.
And we also have Street View.
So, maybe we wanted to go
to coffee and see,
you know,
what's the closest thing
that's not Starbucks.
Um, jump over here.
And...that's it.
Yeah.
There's that coffee shop.
Um...
So this walk score indicates,
you know,
how much can you do
without getting in to a car,
and it's also an indicator
of the vibrancy
of the neighborhood.
And this part
that I just showed you,
this is great for checking out
a specific address.
But what if you want to
get to know a city
on a larger scale.
We did some work where
we generated these heat maps
that can show you in green
the most walkable areas
and fading out to red,
the least walkable.
So this is the map
for Seattle.
You can see,
those who know the city
a little bit,
downtown, Capitol Hill,
University District.
And then you have
these little pockets.
These little neighborhoods
that are
down in Columbia City
and West Seattle
where you have some kind of
little neighborhood.
And this is a great way
to get a quick insight
in to the shape of a city
in terms of,
you know, where people actually
hang out on the streets
and where the--
where the street life is.
So why are we doing all this
work about walkability?
Well, it turns out
the walkability encapsulates
a whole bunch of great things
into one concept
that's very easy for people
to understand.
So a few of those benefits
very quickly.
Climate--If people walk more
they drive less,
they emit less
greenhouse gases.
Health.
People way about seven pounds
on average--
seven pounds less on average
in walkable neighborhoods.
These neighborhoods tend to have
strong social capital,
good transit options,
very few auto-related deaths.
Also a lot
of economic benefits.
home values tend to be higher
or appreciate faster.
Or in this climate,
fall more slowly.
[chuckles]
And transportation costs
are a big part.
They're about 18%
of household income.
Much less
in walkable neighborhoods.
And they tend to have very
strong local economies
where local businesses
can thrive.
It's also something
that people rank very highly
in terms of choosing
where to live.
They say walkability
or access to amenities
is one of the top two things.
Higher than property taxes
or schools.
So what we try to do
is create demand
for walkable neighborhoods
by educating people
about the benefits,
and then fill that demand
by providing transparency
about the walkability
of every property.
And we want to, you know, help
people find these places
and also create more of them.
So walkability matters most,
and this kind
of transparency matters most,
when people are choosing
a place to live.
And that means we need to be
on real estate sites.
So the first thing we did
for that is
built this widget that is
very easy for people to embed.
And this is basically
a miniature version
of what I showed you before.
It's uh, that rectangle part
is what can be embedded
into a real estate site.
And we've seen
a lot of adoption with that.
We've got about twice as much
traffic to that tile
as we do to our website.
So it's been
very successful.
But they often put us down
in the kind of "about
the neighborhood" section,
and it's not really
the ideal placement.
So what we really want
is this.
We want to be right
in the primary information
about a property.
3 bedrooms, 3 bathrooms,
Walk Score: 86
and we want
"Search by Walk Score."
And so to do those things,
we need to build an API
that gives the scores back
to a real estate site
very quickly
so they can just pass us
latitude, longitude
and we give them a score.
They don't want to wait for all
those local searches to happen
and all the restaurants to load
and all that.
Uh...
so we're gonna jump
into the tech stuff now.
And, we'll talk
a little bit about
why we brought EC2
into picture.
Why we didn't just do everything
that we built for the API
on App Engine.
And we'll talk a little bit
about, uh, some guidance
on making Apps scale.
And some issues that
we ran into and thoughts
about working
in the App Engine environment.
I'm gonna hand it over
to Josh to take us in.
Livni: Thanks, Jesse.
All right,
so when we first
were talking about the API,
this is pretty much
our ideal workflow
for the entire API.
All we really want to do
is have a request come in--
latitude, longitude,
location.
It goes through this magic box.
It spits out a score response.
That--that's pretty much it.
And, of course, things get
a little bit more
complicated than that.
But before we get
to the complications,
we had to figure out where
we're gonna host this.
It's pretty straight forward.
We could've run
our own servers.
And so
when we were considering
where to put it,
these were some of the--
These are unfortunately just
the negative considerations
at first glance of App Engine.
But some of the things
we thought about
were vendor lock-in.
If we write code
for App Engine
are going to be able to, uh--
is it portable a little bit?
Because it's similar
to Django,
but we're going to have to
rewrite some things
in case we had to move.
The cost, when we started
this and launched it
there was
no pricing announced.
So we didn't know what
we were in for.
We assumed here it would be,
you now, a competitive cost
to host on App Engine.
And, it's a BETA product.
So, we didn't know.
Is it going to potentially go
down for six to eight hours,
make us look bad?
Are we gonna have
various other problems?
And we decided
after all of this
uh, you know,
that Google engineers
probably are gonna keep
things up better
than we would
with a series of EC2
or other virtual machines.
Cost would be good.
And we weren't super worried
about the portability
of the code.
So we went with App Engine.
And the next step then
is to figure out
what I considered kind of that
core functionality
and the core functionality is
just this.
This is really what we need.
Ability to return responses
really fast.
So the criteria for us
is always, um,
let's go ahead and separate out
this core functionality
from these other pieces.
And I'm gonna show you
some of these other pieces
that we considered
secondary functionality.
Do we put the secondary
functionality on App Engine
where it might conflict
potentially?
Or cause of problems
are core functionality
of returning responses
would fail.
Should we put it
somewhere else?
How do we integrate
these other pieces?
I'm gonna spend
a little time just talking
about some of these
secondary pieces
that we decided
not to put on App Engine
and some that we did.
So App Engine, of course,
is really really good
for simple operations.
Request comes in,
does something basic
such as look at the score,
return it.
Not so good
for certain other things
that it's just maybe not
designed for.
Some of these things Jesse
mentioned,
such as, the rankings.
We have a fairly
complex procedure
to figure out the rankings.
It's not just counting out
points in the polygon
for the different neighborhoods
in the cities.
We bring in all kinds of
demographic data
and weight by population
for each Walk Score.
And App Engine's
not really set up
for that kind of
geo-capabilities.
Some folks I know have done
some backend work with this.
But we do all offloaded
on a PostGIS database.
And so that's offline.
The other is, what if we just
want to look at the API usage.
Who's using stuff in a day,
or a week, or a month.
And where are
the queries coming in?
So this is Seattle API usage
over a given time.
And we want to know
a little bit--
Are people coming in and doing
a--kind of, a survey
or an academic study
where they are going to request
a couple 100,000 points
in a specific area?
Is it people just looking at
houses all over the place
and when?
And this helps us decide
where to pre-calculate points.
We want to make sure we can
respond really fast to places.
So we seed the API
with some obvious things.
Such as all of the sort of,
current places or cities.
Maybe the top 1,000 cities
will score all of the possible
Walk Scores there.
But where else
could we go next?
Uh, by looking at the usage,
we could see things like,
oh, people query for houses
mostly within two miles
of a city center.
And also when we're doing
the rankings,
are we going to rank
over urban areas?
Are we gonna rank over
the statistical
metropolitan stuff
from the census?
So we do this offline
and then precede
the cache offline
with places of interest.
And all this
pre-calculation stuff
brings in a complication
to that really, really
simple work flow,
which is we have
to actually calculate the score
to give it out.
And so the API gets
a little more complicated
if we don't have a score.
We return saying,
"We don't have a score."
Then we have to go
do something about that.
And to just explain
a little bit
why we decided to offload
the scoring portion
outside of App Engine,
I'll hand it over to Dave.
Peck: Okay so, Josh showed us
a number of reasons
that we couldn't strictly
build the Walk Score API
on top of App Engine.
And I'm gonna talk through
sort of the central reason
that we had to make use
of Amazon EC2.
And that's
that as Josh hinted at,
that Walk Score calculation
takes time.
Now calculating the Walk Score
is not CPU intensive,
but it is rather IO intensive.
At a minimum, a Walk Score
requires us to make
17 URL fetches
to Google Local Search
and potentially talk
to other services.
Census services,
Geocoding, et cetera.
Now if you're
an individual user
and you go to our website
and type in an address,
your browser
and our java script
will do most of the work
for you.
But if you're
a real estate company,
what you really want is
programmatic access
and you want us to do the work
of calculating the Walk Score
on your behalf.
And so that's why we built
this API.
So from a customer's
perspective,
the request-response cycle
as Josh mentioned is,
give us the latitude
and longitude,
get back a score
if we've already calculated it.
Otherwise, queue it up.
And, we've actually built
a reliable message
queue abstraction
on top of the App Engine
datastore,
um, to hold on to
the latitudes and longitudes
that we haven't
yet calculated.
Of course, at some point
we have to turn around
and actually service
that queue.
And so we looked at
a few options when we were
building our API.
The first option we looked at
was App Engine cron jobs.
Um, and as you know,
App Engine cron jobs
allow you to regularly ping
an App Engine URL handler.
Um, that URL handler
is subject
to many of the same restrictions
that standard URL handlers
are subject to on App Engine.
So in our case,
making 17 URL fetches
is probably
not going to happen
in the time frame
that App Engine
request response are allowed.
So unfortunately,
cron jobs didn't look like
a particularly good answer.
Um, and of course,
the second thing we looked at
is whether App Engines
supported background tasks.
And obviously if you were
at Brett's talk earlier,
you'll know
that the new task queue API
is going online
in a few weeks.
And we're very excited
about that.
We believe
that we can, uh, move
a lot of our functionality
of our Walk Score calculation
on to App Engine.
But six months ago when we
started building this API,
background tasks weren't
available on App Engine,
so it wasn't
really an option for us.
So where do we turn to?
Well, we turn to Amazon EC2.
For those who don't know,
EC2 is Amazon's API
to spin up virtual servers.
You have full control
of the machine.
You can choose whatever
operating system image you want.
And for us, the things that it
gave us was a place
to do background processing.
The ability to do a number of
arbitrary URL fetches.
Of course, just arbitrary IOs
since you own the machine.
Um, and the design of our
calculator is very parallel.
We have lots
of processes running,
working on different latitudes
and longitudes,
making different
network requests.
We needed a place to run lots
of processes and parallel.
So another words,
the Walk Score API is built
with both App Engine and EC2.
And when you start
to build a service
with multiple cloud
computing environments,
there are a few important
considerations to keep in mind.
So I just want to show
this perspective.
Here we've got the customer's
code on the left.
Our AppEngine code
in the middle
and our Amazon EC2 code
on the right.
Um...and here's
a customer request
where we have already
calculated the score.
They give us the latitude
and longitude.
We check to see that it is
already calculated.
We package up a response and
send it back to them.
And here's the other type of
customer request.
We haven't actually seen it.
The details of what we do
on the App Engine side
aren't really important.
And as Josh mentioned,
it's not very complex.
The important thing
to see here
is that, during the customer
request response cycle,
Amazon EC2 has never
been touched.
So Amazon EC2 is simply
our queue servicing code.
And customer requests
never get to Amazon.
And that's a really important
design point
that I'd urge you to think
about if you're architecting
a API for multiple
cloud services.
Um, for us, what it means is
that our up time
and our scalability is not
a function of both App Engine
and EC2's upside up-time.
Or rather, our down-time is not
a function of both of them.
It's only strictly tied
to App Engine for us.
If Amazon EC2 goes offline,
what that means is that
it'll take a little longer
for us
to process requests
in our queue.
So we've architected this API,
and it's been running
for the last six months.
And I want to talk a little bit
about the behavior we've seen
during the last six months.
So this is sort of
the bottom line thing
that I'd like to stress.
And, of course, App Engine
is a beta service,
so some amount of unpredictable
performance is predictable.
But, uh, we saw
a number of concerning things
along the way
which have really smoothed out
over this beta period.
So the number one thing
that we struggled with
while running our API
in production
is high datastore contention.
And by contention,
what I mean is
when we make a fetch or a put
to the datastore,
we see a time out.
So contention was the percentage
of time outs we saw
in a given set of requests.
And in particular for us,
where we saw contention
was accessing
our queue data structure.
So obviously, customer requests
are coming in
at a rather rapid rate.
They're adding
new latitudes and longitudes
that we haven't calculated yet
to the queue.
At the same time,
our calculator
is trying to pull them off,
computing them,
and then pushing them
back to App Engine,
and removing those entries
from the queue
once they're calculated.
So a typical day for us today
is about a half
of a percent failure
on reading from the queue.
Just two days ago,
at around 1:00am I think,
We saw
App Engine contention rise
up to about 50 or 60 percent
for about six hours.
So a really big surprise.
Something that we had to
architect for
on the Amazon EC2 side
where we are servicing
our queue.
Obviously, we buffer up
a lot of latitudes
and longitudes there
so that if we do--
if we're unable to get data
from App Engine for a while,
we can still continue to
calculate Walk Scores.
So another thing
that could happen during--
especially during
the beta period--
is that the datastore
goes offline
or simply goes
in to Read Only mode.
For those of you who have
running applications
over the last six months,
you'll know that this
has happened from time to time.
What you see normally
in this case,
is when you make a database--
a datastore request,
you see a capability
disabled exception.
Another thing
that we've seen a lot
is that the App Engine
response time increases.
We measured this
on the EC2 side.
So as our calculator
pulls new points
from our App Engine queue,
normally those requests
take about
a half a second to a second.
Every once in a while,
the response time
goes up to several seconds.
So in other words,
latency increases.
Um, App Engine is
a bit of a black box,
so it's hard to always
understand
why this is happening.
You know, with no changes
to your code
and with no changes to your
underlying data models,
you might see this.
And this is
a very rare occurrence,
but has happened once or twice
in the last half-year.
So with those
performance issues in mind,
what can you do to make sure
that your application scales
as far as you need it to?
And so what I'm gonna
talk about here
are sort of the steps
that you can follow
to make your application scale
as far as you'd like.
Um, these steps are distilled
from our experience
building the Walk Score API,
but also building other APIs
on top of App Engine
that we're working on.
So they may not apply
in your condition.
they're just good
rules of thumb to keep in mind
as you're building
your application.
So scalability on any system
is really about stair-steps.
You do a certain amount of work,
you get to the next step.
To get to the step higher
might require substantially
more work on your part.
And so at the bottom rung
for App Engine
when you're just getting
your feet wet,
here are some of the things
that you're code might have.
So first of all,
inconsistent model design.
Either your models
are very large
and you only access
one or two properties
in them at a time.
Or your models are
very small and distributed
and you end up accessing
a cluster of different models
in a single request.
In that case, you probably
want to re-think
the design of your models,
shape them
a little bit differently.
So this is a characteristic
that I've seen
in just starting out
App Engine applications.
Especially for people
who've worked
in the SQL world before
and they're just sort of
starting to move over.
Uneven or no memcache use.
It's a lot of fun
and it's a lot easier
to rate your application
without thinking
about memcache at first.
Unfortunately, pretty much
all good App Engine applications
are going to make some
or very heavy use of memcache
early on in their lifecycle.
Um, and the final thing
is, for those who don't know,
every time you make
a datastore request,
a fetch or a put,
you're effectively making
an RPC request
somewhere in Google's
data center.
So you're able to batch
these requests,
but it can be difficult
to design your code that way.
So a lot of early stage code
that I've seen
doesn't do that.
So with this sort of
naive style of coding
with App Engine,
we've been able to see
something like
five queries a second handled,
which is actually
really rather amazing.
I should point out
that this number is
in our experience--depending
on the type of application
that you're building, you may
see something different,
but this is approximately
what we saw
when we were starting out
with the Walk Score API.
Five queries a second
is over 10,000,000 requests
a month.
It's already a really rather
large application.
And it speaks to the power
of App Engine as a platform
to get you scaling very fast
right out the door.
So where do you go from there
once you want to go past
that five or so queries
a second?
Well, uh, the very first thing
I'd urge you to think about
is starting to use memcache.
And the easiest way
to use memcache
is just slather it on
everywhere you read data
from your datastore.
So the basic behavior,
of course, is
if you're going to read
an entity from the datastore,
check to see
if you've cached it first.
If you have--
great, you're done.
If you haven't--read it,
add it to the cache.
Oh, and be sure
when you're writing back
or updating
an entity in the datastore
to either clear your memcache
or update it.
And if you actually go
and look at
the Google App Engine
Cookbook, somebody uploaded
I think about
a month or two ago
a really great Shim
for the App Engine datastore.
That just causes memcache
on read to happen everywhere.
So as a first step,
that might be something
to look in to.
Um, another thing
to think about
is to batch your datastore
requests where easy.
"Where easy" for us
was anywhere we had
non-nested loops.
So anywhere we had a loop
that we were putting
single entities,
we inverted that.
Now we call "one put"
with lots of entities.
And I should mention
that batching
is a little bit tricky
because you can only fetch
up to a 1,000 entities
of time from the datastore.
And puts are limited
based on the size
of the entities you're putting
in the datastore.
A good rule of thumb is
50 at a time.
So you may need
to have multiple batches
depending on the size
of the operations
you're performing.
So with that work, we saw
pretty much a doubling
of our ability to handle load,
which is actually, again,
really rather impressive.
And that's not so much
engineering work on our part.
But we wanted to go
a lot further.
And of course,
the running Walk Score API
sees substantially more
than ten queries a second
on any given day.
So what do we
have to do next?
And the next of the tips
are really a grab bag of things
that you might
want to think about
as you really scale out
your application.
The first is that I'd urge you
to think long and hard
about how your datastore
is accessed
and what type
of usage patterns you see.
So memcache is really great
in particular
for two types
of usage patterns.
One is repeated requests
to the same data,
and the other is predictable
sequential access to data.
So for repeated requests
to the same data,
if you know your customer
is gonna hit that
same entity again and again,
cache on read,
like we discussed
from the previous step,
is actually really
a great strategy.
But if you have a predictable
sequential access--
For example, in the case
of the Walk Score queue,
we know that we're gonna pull
out those queue items in order.
Our calculator code
is going to request them
in a certain order.
So our calculator
talks to App Engine
and it requests 50 items
at a time from the queue.
But on the App Engine side,
what we do is we actually
pull out a full 1,000 items
from our queue,
put that entire list
in the memcache.
And that obviously
cuts down substantially
on the number of datastore
accesses we need to make.
So think about memcache
usage patterns.
Um...batch all
of your datastore calls.
This went a long way for us
to scaling outward.
And for us, what that meant
is unraveling nested loops.
Sometimes they were loops
that were basically
across method boundaries,
so we had to flatten
a lot of our code out.
But it really
helped us a lot.
As important as using
memcache carefully is,
sometimes it's just not
the right thing to do
to use memcache.
Depending on
your access pattern,
it may not--
memcache may not provide
a very meaningful barrier
between your users
and the datastore.
And that's--
memcache is a limited resource.
You obviously don't want
to populate memcache
with entities
that aren't useful to you
and--and lose
the entities that are.
And, of course, memcache--
when you add items to memcache,
you can, of course, think about
how long they stay there.
Sometimes that's
a very great way
to keep memcache
pressure low.
And then I would urge you
to load test your application.
We actually built
a load testing harness
on Amazon EC2.
We're able to hit our running
Walk Score instances
with over 100 queries
a second.
And that's real load
talking to real URL handlers
that actually do real work
with the datastore.
Um, so load testing.
There are third party products
to help you with that too.
Um, App Engine load
tends to be surprising
once you get pretty high,
past ten queries a second.
And the last thing is,
of course,
monitor your performance.
Now the front line of defense
for monitoring performance
is the--is the App Engine
dashboard,
which is a great place to go.
And, of course, your logs
to look at
individual requests
that, for example, gave you
a datastore time out.
Um, also the system status,
if you're seeing
a lot of latency,
is a good place to go
to just look at the overall
behavior of App Engine.
We actually built our own
performance dashboard
for the Walk Score API,
which we're happy to show you
if you'd like
after this talk.
Um, and it monitors specific
things about the behavior
of our EC2's calculator code
communication with App Engine.
And just sort of one
last technique
if you're getting started
with App Engine coding
that I think everybody
should know, which is,
If at first you don't succeed,
try, try again.
Uh, what we have here
is basically an attempt
to write to the datastore
that time--if it times out,
we're going to turn around
right away and write again.
Just a few
milliseconds later,
you might not
get a time out exception.
And this is something we do
everywhere is our code base now,
both on the read
and write side.
And it's actually
extremely helpful.
So I've talked a little bit
about general principles
for scaling out
App Engine applications.
And what I want to do now
is turn it back over to Josh,
who's going to talk about
one specific instance
where we had some difficult
scalability issues
that we needed to tackle
and the sort of unorthodox
technique we used to solve them.
So thanks.
Livni: Thanks, Dave.
So, yeah,
I started out talking
about kind of
the core functionality
and secondary functionality.
Obviously, you guys'
applications are gonna have
different pieces of secondary
functionality
that may or may not fit
different places.
A really common use case
on App Engine is counting stuff.
I'm gonna talk about
a specific issue we have
counting our users' requests.
We have a basic quota system.
We have an API key.
We want to know
who's basically doing what.
So certain folks might get
a couple hundred thousand
requests a day.
Others might get,
you know,
maybe a couple million a day.
But we want to make sure
that people can't just run away
and abuse the system.
And again, we understand
who's doing what where.
So counting every request
that comes in,
matching it to a user, should be
pretty straight forward.
And the answer that's
usually given for this is,
"Oh, just use
sharded counters."
Every time a request comes in,
write it to
one of these shards.
You're good to go.
But every time a request
comes in,
if that request is, you know,
a 100 requests a second,
that's a lot of shards,
and you're gonna really
hit a lot of datastore
contention.
So we found that the sharded
counters didn't scale
as well as we had hoped.
And what happened,
in our case--
This was from
about six months ago
and things are
a little bit different now.
Around 30,
40 queries a second,
our response time
started creeping up.
You know, two, four,
six plus seconds.
And then
along with the error rates--
And then all of the sudden
everything was 503s.
And this was a really
big problem, because again,
core functionality
should not be hurt
by this sort of
icing on the cake
of counting
who's doing what.
So we were finding
that just because we wanted
to have a quota system,
now nobody can even get a score
because all of the requests
are just bombing out entirely.
So a solution
that we came up with--
How many of you guys
were in the talk
just before this?
Brett's talk next-door?
So a few guys.
So one of the things
I thought--
a really interesting example
of the new task queue
was the backend
sort of writing to a cache.
We implemented something--
a similar concept.
Dave talked a little bit
about using memcache
cleverly on read,
and this is
using memcache on write,
which in the Google group
discussions and other places,
people generally say,
"Oh, don't do that."
You know,
"Memcache is unreliable,
Things might go away."
But in my opinion,
there are certain cases,
and this is one of them
for us,
where you don't absolutely
need to have exact accuracy.
If your writing
a banking application
and counting people's pennies,
you know, don't do this.
But for a lot of cases,
if you're just getting
a general idea for a quota,
how many things are,
you know, generally around
at a given time.
And again,
knowing things might fail,
you have other processes
to come in place
and check
things happened accurately,
do things twice
and so forth.
Using memcache on write can be
a really interesting idea.
So this diagram
basically shows
that request comes in
with the API.
Rather than writing you
a sharded counter,
a datastore counter,
we write to the sharded
memcache counters.
When the memcache counters
fill up to 100,
200, whatever,
only then do we write
that bit of information
to the datastore.
And then the task queue is
a little bit nicer that this.
In the talk just before this,
you notice between the memcache
and the datastore
there's this pass queue,
and it's a lot faster to write
to the upcoming pass queue
that we certainly
weren't expecting
when we started writing this.
But you still
have the same issue
writing to a task queue
or writing to the datastore,
which is there's
this small time period
where requests can come in,
hit your memcache shard,
increment the count
before you've written,
and then cleared
the memcache shard.
So you just have to
sort of keep track
of the delta of what you are
writing the datastore
and then the amount of things
that came in
before you got confirmation.
The same with task queue.
So as I mentioned,
the solution is really nice.
The advantage is really nice.
You get instead of, you know,
100 datastore hits a second,
you get a couple orders
of magnitude less.
And that just scales up
really, really, really nicely.
But the disadvantage is
there is a, uh--
I don't know where
my disadvantage went.
But there's the possibility
that you could lose
a little bit.
And so for our use case,
we were okay
if it was off a little bit
as long as we didn't
over-count.
We didn't want to accidentally
send someone over a quota
that they didn't use.
And so we're just really,
really careful
that in case
of a loss of data,
it's always
a subtle undercount.
And again, memcache has proven
really, really reliable.
There's a couple of, you know,
two-or-three-hour knockouts
that we had that we just
lost counters for.
But aside from that,
as a general rule
you can pretty much
rely on it.
So after we implement
the memcache,
things went like this.
And again, this graph
is from a while ago.
These days, it's smoother
and things stay
well under a second
for the response time.
But it's really a huge
difference.
What it means is, we can
actually count stuff now
at a very, very high
rate per second
and not have to worry
about hitting these issues
where our core functionality
is compromised.
So the summary here is
it's not necessarily
a bad idea
to think about using memcache
on write.
Again, possibility
of lossiness is always there.
But in many cases
that you might come across,
it can really save
not only the possibility
of just datastore contention,
but also some money
because you're charged
for the CPU time
on the datastore.
And if you're not
in the datastore,
you know that can add up,
a few bucks a day
over time.
And then, uh, the other piece
is early on decide,
is this functionality
a good fit for App Engine?
Certain things--for example,
we could've offloaded
the quota, parsed logs
every couple of hours offline
and come back on.
And we decided,
"Oh, this is a good piece
to fit on App Engine."
We ought to be able
to count stuff.
Other things we decided,
"No, this piece,
although integrated
with App Engine and the API,
maybe we'll move off."
So just deciding
which pieces fit in App Engine
is important.
And then the final one
is, of course,
when you're putting
those pieces into App Engine,
make sure that you
write them in such a way
that should strange
and weird things happen--
like all of the sudden
you get popular,
80 queries a second,
datastore contention hits--
those features that you wanted
to have in App Engine
don't compromise
the really core functionality
that your application
may have.
And so with that, I'm gonna
turn it back to Jesse
and talk about
some of the over-all results.
Kocher: So you've seen some
of the, you know, stair-steps
to scalability hotness
that Dave went through.
Um...where has all of that
gotten us?
Well, the three of us--
very small team--
have built an App engine API
that handles over 1.5 million
requests a day.
And, uh, peak rates up to
about 80 requests per second.
So quit a bit higher
than where we started.
Um, and we've come to think
of App Engine
as really being a black box.
It's a place
where things may shift in,
you know,
unexpected ways internally.
And you may not always know
what's going on in there.
Um, but it's also
very well-documented.
And not just the main
documentation online,
but also this dynamic support
with the IRC channel,
the Google Groups,
the issue tracker.
And the App Engine team
is really--
They're--they frequent
all of these places.
So the degree of communication
is pretty amazing,
and it makes working
inside a black box
considerably less daunting.
So our amended statement
would be--
It's a very good black box.
Um, I think looking back
we would make the same choice
that we made, you know,
not knowing a lot of the things
that we've learned
along the way.
And I can say
that having watched App Engine
progress over
these last few months,
the work that we've done
would be considerably easier
starting now
than it was
starting back then.
Um, so we hope this talk
has helped you understand
some of the risks and rewards
of using App Engine
and some things about
how to get your Apps
to scale well.
Um, we have--
I'm gonna put up our contact
info for a second here.
So if you want to get
with us, you can jot that down.
We will also--got some time
for questions here.
And we also will be
out at the demo spot
for most of the rest of
the afternoon until about 4:00.
So if you want to catch us
there, please do.
And we'll move
in to Q&A now.
So we're happy to take
questions on anything.
Uh, we'll take them
at the mic.
And also, I'll flip over
to the, uh,
the Moderator site
in a few minutes.
But before I do that,
I want to put up--
these are a few things
we didn't put into our talk
but we definitely
have more to say about.
So if any of those
interest you,
uh, feel free
to ask about those.
And then, Google sent us
a note earlier today
asking us to direct you all
to havasec.com/io.
And if you go there,
you can put in the time slot
and the session
and you can give feedback.
So we'd appreciate
any feedback you have for us.
Um, and with that, we will
move to questions, so...
man: A two part question
about your counters.
Why did you still shard them
when you put them on memcache?
Kocher: Uh, there actually can
be contention with memcache
when you're hitting it
very intensively.
man: At how many requests
per second would you put that?
Kocher: I don't know.
Do you guys recall?
Livni: Well, we found that
once we hit a--
There's a couple
of reasons we sharded
the memcache counter
originally.
One is, there is that
possibility of contention.
Another is, it's cheap to make
lots of memcache shards.
And one of the issues
I mentioned in that slide
is that as you're writing
the shard to the datastore,
you might not get
a response back
for a half-second
to four seconds.
So all of that time
you're having
a lot more requests
coming in.
We wanted to minimize
to some degree
in order to keep the count
a little--
as accurate as possible.
That very, very small
time frame
from when we clear
the memcache shard is,
"Okay, we got
a confirmation back
and then we've
written it out."
We don't want
30 new requests
coming in
at that time frame
because there is still
a little bit of latency
even writing to memcache.
It's, you know,
much, much faster
that writing the datastore.
And so,
by making lots of shards,
it's not really any overhead
for the system,
but we can sort of spread out
the number of requests
in that just
couple of milliseconds,
it's less likely
we will lose something.
Does that make sense?
man: Okay, the second part is,
before this morning
I--you know,
I didn't really know
how many memcache instances
Google would have for my App.
But now it sounds like
I have to assume
if I write with a key,
it will always be
the same one memcached,
because otherwise
these counters wouldn't work.
You know, if I have
one instance of my Java App
running in Australia--
Peck: No, that's correct.
Memcache is a distributed API.
And so, if you write on--
you don't have any knowledge
of what CPUs your code
is executing on
inside the App Engine
data center.
man: Right, but now it sounds
like I have a guarantee
that when I write to memcache,
all my 500 App instances
write to the same--
Peck: Yeah, they're effectively
writing to the same store.
That's correct.
I don't know how they propagate
that data across.
I don't know how long
it takes.
So, if you're running code--
not that you can specify
when you're writing
an App Engine application
right now.
But if some of your code's
running in Australia
and some of it's
running here,
I don't know how long
that would take to propagate.
But, yes, it looks like
you see a consistent view
of the memcache world regardless
of where your code is.
man: Just surprised
that that's future-proof,
because, you know, once you get
to the Facebook scale,
maybe you guys--maybe you
need multiple memcache...
Peck: Yeah!
man: for the same writer.
Livni: Yeah, I mean,
we've had good luck with it,
but I'd say that's
a really good question
for the folks
who actually built it.
Would have, uh,
better answers than we would.
Kocher: They also have a--
you know, the memcache
has a certain size
and, you know,
the more you put in there,
the more you increase pressure
on your memcache
and the sooner things
will expire from it.
So there's really
a--a balancing act
about figuring out
which things to put in there.
Um, and, you know,,
the size of your entities
matters when you're
putting things in.
So choosing that, you're--
you're making
a lot of decisions
that will affect
how available that data is
when you go back
to look for it later.
Livni: I think there's one
actually small thing
I should mention on that,
which is when you write
to a memcache,
I believe it gets deleted.
First created, first out.
Not last updated, uh, out.
And so when we refresh
on memcache key,
I believe we delete the key
and then recreate it.
rather than just updating it.
So that way,
it's got a fresher date
and is less likely
to get migrated
should more contention
happen in memcache.
man: I have a couple
of questions.
First is about your API.
You sort of had
a very simple diagram,
but the queuing that you do
when you don't have
the latitude and the longitude,
does your API
just return queued up?
Like, I mean,
in case the query is for--
for a latitude and longitude
that you haven't calculated,
do you just return queued up?
Peck: Yeah, that's right.
Our API returns
to the customer
"Try back later" basically.
If you think
about the typical use case
of embedding
in a real estate site,
what that means is
the customer doesn't display
the walk score that time,
but the next time
that one of their users
comes and looks
at that same property,
we'll probably have
that walk score queued up
and ready for them.
Man: Okay.
And the other question
is about, uh--
So you use this metric
of queries per second
when you were describing
the techniques to speed up,
like using memcache
and everything.
Kocher: Yeah.
man: So this queries
per second I'm assuming
is like datastore queries
that you are saying, right?
Peck: Oh, no.
When I was showing those
queries per second numbers,
what I was showing
is the number
of your successful
URL requests
that someone outside of our--
of the App Engine data center
can make to our application
and get running correctly.
And those numbers were rough.
They won't apply
to your application exactly,
but that's approximately what
we saw in the development
of the Walk Score API.
Livni: They're also a little
bit better now.
If you were
to write the same App
that we did early on,
you would get, I think,
much higher queries
per second today
than eight months ago.
Peck: Yeah, I mean,
the bottom line message is that
with---even with naive code
you can actually scale out
pretty far with App Engine.
It's pretty impressive.
man: I have two questions.
The first one is,
are you now running
your entire production
frontend off of App Engine?
Peck: Yes, we do.
man: So if we go to
www.walkscore.com, it's--
Kocher: Oh, right.
No, we're only doing
the API there.
Uh, we are looking at--
we're considering
moving other parts.
You know, either the tile
or potentially even
the whole website over.
And, uh, you could mention
quickly the Caucho stuff.
Peck: Yeah, yesterday--
so the Walk Score website itself
is actually written in PHP.
Um, and as you know,
JVM now on App Engine.
And there's a company here
called Caucho
which makes a PHP implementation
for--for the JVM.
And actually yesterday,
we're able to
port our entire PHP website
over to App Engine.
And we just started
testing it,
but it looks like
it's extremely performing,
which is impressive.
It's a lot faster
than running Apache
on a private server
at some randomized P.
Um, yeah, the API itself,
however, is all,
of course, Python
and App Engine code.
man: And second question is,
have you run into any of
the big limits of App Engine
in terms of the storage index
as you mentioned
in your last slide?
Have there been
any big things
where you end up
having to be billed
for a lot more
than you expected?
Kocher: Uh, we haven't.
They--they gave us, you know,
as early users of--
early high traffic users,
they gave us access
to go beyond those
initial free quotas,
you know, before
the billing was enabled.
Now that billing is enabled,
there's a lot more
flexibility to go,
and you can use a lot.
So we haven't really run
into those limits.
I think the things
that are interesting
are the per request limits
of, you know,
how much CPU time you can use
and how much time
you can use it.
We have, uh,
some of the EC2
to App Engine communication.
Some of those things do--
they use way more CPU time
than App Engine
is really happy with.
But because they're much less
frequent than the public calls
that come in at
a much higher rate,
we can manage those.
And we use some backing off
techniques where if EC2
has trouble communicating
it can say,
"Oh, we're gonna stop
talking to App Engine
for a little while.
Stop hitting it with these
high CPU-intensive requests."
Peck: If you want,
I can take this.
Kocher: Um, sure.
Peck: Uh, so considering
that calculating walk scores
requires considerable time,
would you consider
using web hooks?
And actually,
I was in Brett's talk
just--just previous,
and the answer is yes.
I think we'd love
to use web hooks.
We haven't used them yet.
Uh, but it might be something
for us to look at.
And certainly
for those who were there,
I think you've
probably guessed
that a lot
of our calculator code
fits nicely with the task queue
API that he described.
Kocher: Um, yes, go ahead.
man: Could you please
elaborate a little bit
into how you implemented
the, um--
how you implemented
between the queries
of your App Engine
and the computational intensive
part of Amazon EC2?
Peck: Sure, I mean,
I can dig a little more
into the design
of the calculator.
Um...basically,
the calculator is currently--
Wow, okay we got
a bunch of random stuff.
Um, so the calculator is,
of course,
completely running on at EC2.
And it's actually running
on a single machine,
but it's lots
and lots of processes.
Kocher: Do you want to jump
to the slide in here?
Peck: Actually, I wanted
to jump to that one.
And so
the key thing that we saw
because of the unpredictable
performance reading
from the queue
that we've implemented
on the App Engine side
is that we wanted
to decouple the computation
of a walk score
from the IO address we made.
So what we have
is a master process
that spawns off
a ton of slaves.
Some of those slaves
are responsible
for talking to App Engine
and requesting
new latitudes and longitudes
that we need to calculate.
Um, and what we do is we
have a rather large buffer
on the Amazon EC2 side
of latitudes and longitudes
coming in
so that if we can't talk
to App Engine for a while,
we can continue
to calculate scores.
Uh, so that's
one major thing.
We basically decoupled
our IO
from our computation
on the EC2 side
and we buffered all our IO.
Um, and sort of one last point
which Jesse alluded to
is that we dynamically respond
to the changing IO conditions.
So if App Engine is--
if contention is very high
for more than, say,
10 or 15 requests in a row,
what we do
is we actually back off
and stop talking
to App Engine for a while.
And, um, for various reasons
based on the internal design
of the datastore,
that's something that can
actually alleviate contention
if we come back
20 minutes later
and just work through
the buffer--
the data that's buffered
on the EC2 side.
So that's--that's sort of
the big picture of the design
of of the calculator.
man: All right so it was--
it was roughly one database
and you used rsync or something
like that between--
Peck: Oh, so--so
actually App Engine
is our data master.
All of our data is there.
Um, all of the points
that we're working on
on the EC2 side
are simply held in RAM.
If that process crashes,
it's not the end of the world.
We basically
might redo a few points.
Um, we actually--
the EC2 code is also Python,
so if we--
if we except out of a process,
we actually just pickle out
all the current data.
So...
man: Okay, thanks.
Kocher: Any other questions?
Peck: Do we have
Moderator questions?
Kocher: That was
the only one.
Peck: That was it.
Thanks, guys.
Livni: Yep, thanks, guys.
[applause]